this is why the cakes on nailed it look
the way they do
there's a lot of running in this stop
the timer i need a break
hey guys it's me jasmine and i love food
reality shows one that i found very
entertaining was mailed it on netflix so
on the show they have these amateur
bakers bake these super elaborate cakes
in a very short amount of time so they
have this one episode where they're
building this super massive shark attack
cake and they had to build it in two and
a half hours i mean it just seems
impossibly difficult there's so many
components so many little details i just
feel like this is only something that a
professional can do so what i'm gonna do
today is try the same exact challenge
with the same exact time limit and see
if it's
really doable
do you think i could do it no
nice
i don't know if i'm gonna be able to
accomplish this but you know what it's
fine it's fine it's all fine it's all
great okay ready set
go
okay i'm gonna just make the yellow cake
first i'm gonna breeze through this very
quickly because
madness
all right i'm going to cream the butter
and sugar for now but yeah i'm just
going to breeze through the batter
portion of this and then get to
decorating i'm going to devote most of
the time to decorating mix faster cream
faster
all right while that's going i want to
start cracking my eggs usually i'll do
it one at a time but today i don't care
because time is of
the essence
all right sorry don't come at me
alright i'm gonna sit these together
very efficient with your time
i have to be there's not much of it
it doesn't have to be the most perfect
cake ever just needs to taste good and
look good yeah see usually i would do
this little by little but
okay
butter milk is in
i gotta split this into two now
i got my greased pans here
do a little bit out of time so it's even
i'm gonna throw these in the oven and do
this like five more times
all right i'm feeling pretty confident
right now i got all the cakes into the
oven pretty fast while that's baking i'm
gonna try to use my time efficiently and
start making the buttercream frosting
[Music]
i need things to move faster time stops
for no one jasmine would you consider
yourself an amateur baker um you know i
would not my specialty is within cooking
savory stuff i do enjoy baking
i'm decent at it but this is just a
really large cake i think i've made like
10 cakes in my whole life i'm gonna add
in some powdered sugar now
oh this part's just gonna
it's gonna
explode
i'm just gonna add a splash of
this to loosen it a little goes a long
way
i have to make a bunch of buttercream
because it's going to be the waves at
the bottom of this shark attack cake
it's also going to serve as the glue
to hold the cakes together very
important oh we're also going to need it
for the crumb coat so the fondant has
something to stick to all right this is
done we're going to make some more
buttercream and then go check on the
cakes
i'm waiting for the cakes to chill and i
can't move on until it's chilled
adequately so i'm just
letting time tick away
seems like a big waste of time
all right i aborted mission i'm not
letting it chill for any longer because
i just need the time to decorate i have
an hour and a half left
let's do this i'm putting some frosting
at the bottom so it'll stick okay hold
on you know what i'm just i'll carve it
down i'll carve it down
things are getting real now this is very
hard if i don't have a good structure
i'm just not going to be able to
make a good cake or a
decent cake oh my goodness it's not
chilled enough yeah i really hope the
structure doesn't get messed up if it
does i know exactly
where it went wrong
it's so hard to spread this after i
frost this i'm gonna use that second
layer and stack it and then i have a
bunch of the round cakes i made earlier
i'm gonna stack those on top i'm really
ripping this cake apart you know it
might have been a huge failure to take
this out of the
freezer early
everything eventually is just going to
get covered up so this doesn't have to
be super pretty
oh
oh my god
okay i'm going to cut off the corners
anyway so i'm not too worried about
that oh
i broke it
all the contestants deal with this
madness so i'm just gonna
carve around the mistakes let's add some
more frosting
do you see it ripping maybe i should let
it chill for longer
it's falling apart and this is the
foundation the show sets too high of
expectations they have to make these
crazy cakes and they have like no time
to do it how are they supposed to
succeed i don't even think the person
who made the original cake got that same
time limit i don't think so where's the
truth
okay now i gotta cut the tops off these
cakes i'm cutting these so they stay
flat and even as i stack them and the
cake won't top all over the big cakes
are gonna be the body
of the shark
and then the top one are slightly
smaller because the shark's body will
build and get more narrow especially the
nose
[Music]
this right here is like the base like
right below the shark's belly i would
never make it on one of these food shows
the pressure is too high i really don't
want this cake to fall over so i'm going
to put some dowels in there not too far
to the edge because i know i'm going to
carve it oh these are quite long just
going to trim these
[Music]
okay got it
breaking a sweat
honestly so far so good i really thought
this was going to be a mess at this
point so i'm quite happy with where we
are at the moment i'm now stacking my
smaller sized cakes so that means we're
getting closer to the top of the shark i
don't know how i'm going to make the
mouth yet i don't know we got one more
layer left gotta get these dowels in
here so it doesn't fall over
left a little space for this baby
perfect
i am trying to envision a shark and then
i'm gonna carve it into the shark i'm
gonna have to slant it this way go back
a little bit like this for the mouth
maybe
i don't know if that's possible anymore
actually i'm gonna do like a very
forgiving carve so there's room to fix
things you have less than an hour left
at this point god are you serious i'm
less than an hour
i feel like as i carve it's just getting
harder to keep still and the shakiness
is making me very wary all right i
really need to figure out this mouth
situation i'm gonna stick it like this
and have the tops rest against it and
then cover the dowels with the frosting
i just really hope this doesn't break
i'm gonna add this on top just to make
it a little more
that's not that bad this makes a lot
more sense now getting the the main
shape of this is is taking a lot more
time than i imagined i'm scared that the
mouth will fall apart and i'm scared to
pick it up because it's already in place
all right i'm going to approach this
with a cake pop sort of concept and mush
everything together add some frosting
also reduce waste yeah it's all going to
get covered anyway so it'll be hey okay
this top down shot looks uh scarier than
what the shark is supposed to look like
it's a big mouth
mouth open wide
what that mouth do
it's humongous he's like so ready to eat
this guy's starting to tilt backwards so
i want it to stand up a little
straighter i'm going to add just some
some more cake to the back here it's
like sinking now i'm going to apply the
crumb coat i've never done this before
but uh it'll be fine i'm just going to
get this done as fast as possible
because time is a chicken i just
finished the crumb coat i gotta add the
fondant the original cake had like a
surfer and a surfboard on it i don't
have more time to talk actually i am a
little worried right now because i've
never worked with fondant before it
feels tough but i got a really heavy
rolling pin i think i need to make it
thicker at the top because of gravity
and it'll pull it and i don't want it to
rip but i've washed enough of cake boss
to know what can go wrong i am not gonna
dye it because incorporating the color
into the fondant is going to take way
too long so i am going to spray it with
the color
i think this could be good i'm just
running low on time so there's not
enough time to be so precious you know
what i mean it's not long enough
the dowel
i'm miserable at the moment
i'm gonna cut it here i'll cover it
later with some decoration oh god this
cake is so big
oh my god look how much it's splitting
oh my goodness at what point is giving
up acceptable oh no i can't let go i
can't let go it's gonna break it's gonna
break
i gotta roll out my next piece
oh i need that oh my god what am i doing
it actually ends up rolling out faster
when you do it slowly it's a very
strange shape that i did you know what
i'm not gonna worry about that part
either because i can just cover that up
with waves i really want to make it
perfect but i need five more hours
we're gonna do coloring food coloring
spray
we're gonna color our shark all right
next uh okay mouth let's do the mouth
no
that's way brighter than i was trying to
go for so i'm very upset about how this
turned out but you know what it's i
don't i don't have any time so it's just
it's gonna be like this
gotta move on i'm gonna have little
wrinkles in his mouth right here
you know what i don't like that let's
let's not do that anymore sharks have
multiple rows of teeth so gonna cut out
some sharp teeth okay this shark is not
gonna have too many teeth this is
sticking better than i thought i thought
it was gonna fall off immediately please
don't come at me for the anatomy i
really don't know how the rows of teeth
work i just know rose exists i was doing
the two rows of teeth for the shark but
i ran out of triangles i just really
don't have time i've removed one of the
rows of teeth and i'm just gonna put on
the bottom layer of the mouth just to
save time
okay so you have 15 minutes left no
take it back oh my goodness oh my
goodness i have like literally so much
to do
oh looks like boba
all right while that dries i'm gonna
make the uh surfboard
i'm making the little surfboard tail
thingy
my surfboard
all right so i need two legs so this guy
is gonna be inside the shark's mouth
getting eaten making the toes thankfully
you don't see his full body on the cake
so i only need to make the legs and
pants
lovely trunks my friend
so bad all right what's next really
running out of time here going to throw
on my blue frosting
no
i'm getting it everywhere but the cake
you know waves are never predictable so
i think any shape and like angle that
i'm putting it on is correct
i'm unrolling the licorice now this is
the surfboard string
okay that's just gonna go there oh god
this is not where a surfboard string
goes you know what it doesn't matter the
string was lost
oh the eyes the eyes the eyesight
it looks so weird i gotta give his nose
four
step away
you can't do this in two and a half
hours and have it look like perfection
i think i did better than i thought i
would i think it came out better than
some of the other contestants cakes but
at the end of the day i think i was set
up for failure but it's fine we got
freddy over here now it's time to invite
kelly and annie over here to see if they
think i nailed it or failed it
i think jasmine did amazing i'm honestly
super impressed the swim shorts like
perfectly fit the leg and even the eyes
like they're like kind of beady like a
sharks it's really realistic one thing
that is missing is the blood drooling
out of his mouth which would have been a
really fun detail but she was down to
the wire and she still did great do you
think i nailed it or failed it i think
jasmine nailed it it's cool and
impressive um it's very colorful it
feels like although you're making a very
sort of soulless creature in a shark i
feel like i understand jasmine's energy
in it the coloring on it's super cool if
i was like peekaboo okay this is a shark
i clearly know what it is so overall do
you think i nailed it or failed it it's
somewhere in the middle we all feel like
we can nail things a little bit better
next time maybe that's just the
situation here the one thing i like the
most is that the texture of the spray is
very similar to like an actual shark a
very slippery like shiny finish all
right so annie do you think i nailed it
or failed it i think you nailed it
good work oh my god
[Music]
i know
oh yes
you